welcome to this video playing Prince
panic Willie Hendricks from the
Netherlands yeah okay let's play this
baloney why not I have white against him
for once this is not happening often i
usually have black I don't know why but
i usually have black did I ever have
wide actually with white I have two wins
here two wins zero losses and with black
okay I'm a little bit struggling yeah
benoni I didn't even know what is
playing against you for how we I always
remember I always remember that I have
them how is it called have the Italian
game against him one of the time with
black okay so we have a very
old-fashioned form of benoni here why
not pre moving I are interesting how
interesting does he want to take their
1c3 hmm it's an interesting idea
hmm how interesting don't want that
really have looked so that looks
interesting for him but he has some know
then bishop then 95mm now okay okay yeah
that's assets aggressive a really
aggressive play but also weakening
especially is six is very weak so if I
go F for here marca de the best one is
probably just really preparing things to
the fullest we should be too then later
a form he does not have any any move to
prevent it anyway nie Dage five here
maybe okay i have to prevent him from
going F for himself so i have to go
ahead for now then bishop t2
and try to use this weekend square he
might play night age five and Bishop d4
but I don't mind that so much I should
have everything nicely covered I need
tactic song I don't see it I want any g3
of course yeah g3 adheres to drop back
yeah what I want here is an endgame
really just an end game where I have two
bishops and I can torch him with g 4 and
so on just trade rook straight Queens
this is all a neat here nothing fancy
Queen B 6 no not trying for any
substantial counterplay proof this a
little bit and train going to trade
trade rooks now yeah no no worries there
b5 wasn't threatening but a four is ok
Bishop see to a fort so was an idea
earlier but yeah hmm I just want to
trade everything here the end game is
really nice check yeah this is this end
game time is endgame type is known from
the Arabic Kings Indian and it is a
total torture huh black
I only have two not blunder stuff or do
something really stupid and this is
going to be very awkward for him
now white space advantage is very very
annoying to to face right here yes to
ask himself if I'm threatening to take
on f5 and just win the pawn with Bishop
d3 that's actually quite serious already
and he definitely doesn't want to take
but he has to maybe he has to and now g5
Bishop g4 is coming this is a dream end
game okay that's a good a good move on
interesting move to trying to defend it
would take it 97 but still has two left
to do this right takes 97 and be 395
facets it's still good after do it and
maybe he can
when to play night before in this
position but he can take be to sobe
three okay can take c3 and take g5 but
he doesn't do that ok so I'm going to
keep the night and maybe Bishop d3 add
Bishop d3 of course ok yeah I'm spoiling
not I'm not that I'm spoiling much but
Bishop d3 was stronger just attacking
the pawn I'm still able to do that now
maybe yeah I am so we'll check can also
take take form for g6 Bishop h700 g6
chap ok this cannot be bad really
getting this in and now maybe just here
for g6
yep Beck
the ship doesn't have great squares
ready okay so check Bishop to see eight
is an additional problem let's see
Bishop f4 mmm yeah night to e4 well
maybe 96 is still a willing well it
probably holds still does we should be
five now time morning okay it's not a
good that's not a trade I workable but I
have night f6 coming you're taking age
seven
I was sorry nope I'm luba nning the
point don't twisting my tone here black
resign yeah it was nice I think this was
a it looked like a good in good game he
traded down to this somewhat somewhat
problematic end game which is a very
well known position type that happens
out of the Kings in your Nava back all
the time it was really it's difficult to
play this type of position because you
don't have a clear idea what to do with
black the problem is if we just look at
the end game I'd really have a hard time
to determine um what you should do but
it's clear that Jessia this is a very
very nice endgame if you want to see
more of it I had a tournament game with
this end game against Grandmaster power
which last year 2014 in my maracas open
and which I failed to win unfortunately
it was a very nice position but he
defended successfully and here we see
one point of this end game wyd wins
Norman's amount of space and if black is
not taking I mean it's not so clear what
you should play but let's say you place
a king or something the problem is I'm
attacking here now like here and this is
Pawn is probably not going to hold for
long they're 5.1 92 2 g-3 the other
problem in general is a structure a
structure like that if you go 94 and
maybe man this particular case i will
need forward let's say this structure if
you think of this structure i have a
very clear plain IAM with white i can
show you black black it's not able to do
anything i'm going to push everything up
all the way and now my plan is to do
this at the end and those points will
win I know this sounds very elaborate
and very long but this is going to work
it's just like that the pawns advance
first and then you sacrifice on
five and ultimately you win add this in
a tournament game against the feeder
master once was quite funny because I
could play all those moves instantly
almost the plan is well-known like h5 h6
and then you sacrifice on FF and black
is just sitting there I cannot do
anything it was a very uncomfortable end
game I'm not sure where he should
improve to be honest he drifted into
this this position I think this just
didn't help very much I don't mind this
formation it takes important squares
away yeah it was nice very nice ok I
hope you enjoyed this thanks for
watching